let's read this first story from
timcast.com
washington post publishes home address
of popular critic of left libs of tick
tock reporter taylor lorenz has
previously claimed to suffer from ptsd
from being doxed in a similar way
now i want to show you a little bit here
and i got to explain a lot of the nuance
all right they say an article by a
technology reporter the washington post
provided the home address of the creator
of the libs of tiktok twitter account
in an article meant to expose the person
behind the popular account reporter
taylor lorenz linked to a critical piece
of information that disclosed the
private home address of the person
running libs of tick tock after the
ensuing backlash the post removed the
link tim cast confirmed that the address
published is documented as the creator's
private home address now i will say uh
we were all in the newsroom going over
this investigating details everybody
kind of contributed to uh working on
this story and we did end up pulling
public records which confirmed the
original story published by the
washington post contained a link to two
different links to two addresses one
address was the address of the creator
of libs of tick tock the other address
was the address of family members now
here's the challenge if i pull up the
archive to prove they're lying about
this it will expose the name of the
creator of libs of tick tock which i
don't want to do
well i suppose we have no choice well
it's kind of like showing cuties to talk
about how bad cuties is no no look the
washington post published a lie should
we show their lie and prove them lying i
don't think we should choke well i think
i think you can show no not the address
no no you can show the oh wait is it in
the screenshot in in the tweet from the
washington post where they lie right
they use the name of the creator of libs
of tick tock
right and they're unlocked you can at
least show the i believe the screenshot
of the original article which shows the
hyperlink it just still has the name
there see they put the names
they put the name everywhere i think
this is on purpose by the way i think i
think it's by design i think it's silly
for us at this point to be like people
can't find the name yeah exactly anybody
should anybody could look at my twitter
account right now in washington post i
think we don't need to show it people
believe us if you really don't believe
us go search for yourself oh i think
that's i think it's we're being
ridiculous at this point to be like oh
we're not gonna say the name even though
literally it's all over twitter
everywhere it's trending well even
stephen crowder mentioned it the eric
the eric charamella
crowder did
crowder did say uh the name of the the
creator yeah he did well then we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna go with it
yeah
so uh we have this from christine karate
kelly statement from cameron barr
re-reporting from taylor lorenz they
said taylor lorenz is an accomplished
and diligent journalist whose reporting
methods comport entirely with the
washington post's professional standards
chaya raichek in her management of the
libs of tiktok twitter account and in
media interviews has had significant
impact on public discourse and her
identity had become public knowledge on
social media we did not publish or link
to any details about her personal life
cameron barr senior managing editor of
the washington post
tim poole can confirm that is a lie
i tweeted this is the game they play
effing evil people as evil as they come
there's the archive there's your proof
sorry to libs of tick tock for dealing
with this but wapo needs to be exposed
and proven to be liars here is the
archive of the first version of their
story and i'm going to read it it is
archive.ph slash capital b lowercase e
capital v i believe it's an l lowercase
l and lowercase o and they linked to
right here if i click that right now it
will show you the address of libs of
tick tock we pulled up private uh we
pulled up public records it was a a paid
public record search a little bit deeper
than you normally go and confirmed this
is documented as the private home
residence of the creative libs of tick
tock i i apologize that we've come to
this point we had we had deep ethical uh
conundrums and debates in the newsroom
about whether or not we exposed the
washington post having done this because
we're effectively amplifying their docs
by doing so but i said anything that
happens at this point is on the
washington post anything bad that
happens is on them and we need to call
it out
because
if we say nothing they they are not held
to account for having done it that being
said
it is possible this is no longer the
current address of the individual
there's other other issues at play but
they also published another address
which is the we we believe based on
reported the reporting that we've done
is the family address of the individual
now you're crossing the line for what
reason did they have to do that now i
reached out to taylor lorenz and said we
can confirm you publish the private home
address of the creator of libs of tick
tock
do you have a comment to which she
responded i did not so she's saying she
posted a link to it and that's the hill
they're going to die on it's not they're
saying it's not the same that all shows
i did not no no no no because in the
statement it says link right
it says we did not link to so in the
statement so in the statement from
taylor to you she's saying i did not
publish in the statement from the
washington post which came out like 12
hours after the actual article itself
went live they claim they did not link
after they themselves positively went
into the archive removed the link which
we can only now see in the archive
version
that's right so they're lying about
doing it
taylor is lying about doing it i suppose
her only argument is that she doesn't
believe
it's the private home address
but i'm sorry uh how would she know that
did she actually i asked her
i i didn't i didn't just ask you know
why did you do this i sent a comment and
uh because i gotta be honest i'll give
taylor this respect she responds
every time there's been an issue she's
responded she's actually corrected
things before so i can respect that and
i said we're gonna be publishing the
story
i can confirm you published the private
home address of the creator of libs of
tick tock i asked two questions
why was the link removed
and did you check the address in the
link you posted before publishing it and
her response was i did not publish the
private home address and then directed
me to washington post pr if that's the
only thing she has to say i can only
respond with that is an incorrect
statement outright falsifiable because
i i'm not going to publish the documents
that we have because it's a paid search
you can dig up public records that are
not
i'll put this well is it it's publicly
available but it's through like a paid
investigator investigative service
to get these records like you'd have to
go and physically like ask and just go
to the county or something we got them
we're not going to publish them
but i i can say it's a statement to fact
washington post did publish the private
sector
libs of tick tock is her contention
because this has to do with the fact
that
um libs i guess was a real estate sales
person and that this was the registered
address
of her as a business entity working as a
real estate working in real estate sales
retailers trying to hide behind well
even even if that's the case what is the
good in publishing that why would you
have any reason to do so in order to do
an exposure well it's at the very least
i'm trying to understand but let me let
me i want to make sure we get to the
real nuance here the real context the
link they published was a real estate
license which had the address of an llc
right however the address used by the
llc is actually a split building with
with multiple apartments and a
storefront
on google maps the storefront is a salon
so i said okay well wait a minute it is
common for people to use their own
address for their llc's all the time
regardless of whatever reason i have no
idea why there's other employees listed
within the llc that address we did the
record search and it and it's it's it is
listed in public records as a private
residence of this individual so
that's on the washington post if they
would like to explain that
feel free to as it stands right now we
pulled public records it's a private
home address and they published the
address anyone else can do it and
anything that happens at this point is
on the washington post for doing it i've
got to point out some some i guess
nuance because posting something and
posting a link to something are
different as an advent a social media
administrator and if someone posts
something illegal they go to jail if
someone posts a link to it they're
allowed to not true well it is as an
admin you don't you remove the original
piece but you don't hammer everyone that
retweeted it that's insane we're not
talking about we're not talking about
sharing a post we're talking about them
taking the link to the address and
putting it in the article was this not
already public information
it so
the name of the individual is not public
so they put some pieces together so if
no one knows the name of the person then
it doesn't matter what is public if you
then say here's their name
and here's a link to their address
you've doxed them you've published your
address and i got to be honest that is
the nuclear bomb of doxing but but
they're trying to argue this is not
doxing when you post their name and then
with a link next to it saying here's
their home address you've doxxed is that
illegal
no no maybe it should be in the 21st
century free speech
the the thing that the thing that i
think we do need to add though is that
the washington post is not the one that
did all this work and taylor lorenz is
not certainly not the one who did all
this work she is piggybacking awful work
that was done by pro antifa accounts
over the weekend people that have been
doxing
online accounts on the right and
conservatives for years with
ongoing harassment campaigns some of
which by the way we're starting to hear
may receive foreign government funding
well
well i can't what i can say is
what is what is very much ignored by
this is that taylor lorenz did receive
information from activists published it
as if it was her story and used the the
washington post matthew iglesias of
vox.com which is a left-wing publication
he's no longer with them anymore but
this is
yeah he's one of them he started it but
then he left yeah he said get a great
take
is that this article is basically framed
as libs of tick tock bad
but then it provides you with no real
thesis or argument as to why that's the
case there's a story
it's basically
it is active as a masquerading as news
yes there is no story he said it turns
out that the crux of the story who is
this person turns out she's a random
crank of no of you know no public
notoriety so why was that relevant this
is um do you remember when they docked
when uh i think it was buzzfeed carpe
duncan oh and and they said oh the
pro-trump meme maker and they found that
he's a stay-at-home father of four who
lives in kansas city he's just like a
regular
guy i mean he raises his kids and makes
memes as opposed to sheamus who raises
other people's children
by the way for them
uh but but you lift them up sheamus what
do you mean all the children of earth oh
i got i gotta i gotta i gotta pull
something up real quick when you go to
the spj ethics code and
i think i'm going to have to shrink this
so you can see it there we go you can
see minimize harm in large black bold
letters and it says
recognize that legal access to
information differs from an ethical
justification to publish or broadcasting
here we go this is the society for
professional journalists standard of
ethics now there's others there's
reuters i think the ap has theirs but
this is spj which is what they teach you
in schools and um the the point being
brought up here is you minimize harm
within minimize harm they literally say
just because information may be public
or you have legal access to it doesn't
mean you should broadcast it which is
the challenge we had in our newsroom
because we're like we can confirm this
is a private home address but do we do
we push that out because that'll that'll
that'll potentially cause harm you know
this is the oh real quick it was a coin
toss for us we ultimately decided that
the public's right to know what major
corporations are doing with the power of
billionaires
outweighed the potential harms because
the harm of not exposing this was
greater than the harms to the individual
so with that you know i apologize to
libs of tick tock for being caught up in
this but we are not the ones who
supposed to be a tough one because do
you expose medusa to the crowd to show
them that it's medusa because if they
see it they'll turn to stone
well i mean and what are they exposing
this person makes videos on the internet
that make fun of other people in fact
they're not even doing that they're just
posting other things that people have
said which were already ridiculous
things there would be a story if there
were some i don't know funded effort
behind this that was being obfuscated or
if there were some nefarious you know
organization behind the lib something
like that but there's no story here
there's no story whatsoever this is the
point i brought up earlier
what
is served by saying the two words that
is the private name of the individual
nothing now
the story could be the person running
the account was at january 6th as
reported i think that's new i think it's
relevant interesting what is the mo what
are the motivations of this person right
the opinions of the individual also oh
okay so this person also said these
things that's relevant but you can tell
that story without saying their name
saying the name only serves to maximize
potential harm well so what i was gonna
say this is the opposite argument that
you hear in uh that came up with the
katanji braun jackson hearings when she
was talking about some of the decisions
and articles she had written when she
was in law school regarding sex offender
registries and the idea being that if
you make a mistake once in your life it
shouldn't follow you for the rest of
your life forever so the idea was to
minimize harm to potential sex offend or
to convicted sex offenders that over
time you would be able to
reduce the amount of time essentially
that you would appear in the registry
that's the exact argument that was being
made for sex offenders right versus this
one which is minimize harm completely
for just the subjects of journalism so
taylor lorenz right is is maximizing
harm to someone who runs
an aggregator of again public videos
that are already out there videos again
that are made to be shared and obviously
it's you know
it's not it's not hypocrisy it's
hierarchy that's kind of the main thing
the main thrust of all this because we
can say all day long that oh it's
hypocrisy you're doing
you're exposing you're writing you're
doing all this stuff but it's it's not
hypocrisy it's hierarchy they're allowed
to do it taylor lorenz is allowed to do
it uh because she is of the anointed
class she is of the upper class she is
of the aristocracy and the fact the
matter is that because libs of tick tock
was not anointed she didn't go to the
right school she didn't get the right
credentials she was doing this
unauthorized then she's not allowed to
because keep in mind taylor lorenz used
to be a tick-tock journalist herself and
she would go in specifically posting
videos from kellyanne conway's 13 year
old daughter and all sorts of other
people across tick tock and instagram
and she was doxing pamela geller's
daughters at the same time this is what
she did at the end of the day taylor
lorenz is jealous that libs of tick tock
was able to become more influential and
more effective and more do more
long-lasting reporting just from looking
at tick-tock videos than taylor lorenz
will ever do in her entire life
you said earlier that there was like
foreign actors potentially involved with
uh activist groups that are working in
the boxing yeah is that confirmed or is
this just stuff you've heard it is
convert do you have evidence is there
evidence around that we can pull up or
is it is it something we should we
should we should wait until we have the
bigger story the release yeah because i
don't want to get into yeah it's not
it's not research on the earth
i like pulling up sources for this it is
a rabbit hole but the idea is that the
person who conducted the initial docs
is actually receiving funding from
foreign governments
well we've talked about this before the
washington post is not exactly the most
reputable and responsible publication
out there so i'm sure you all remember
that these are the people who spread the
mistruths about nick sandman and part of
why i'm bringing that up right now is
because even though you mentioned it
isn't necessarily illegal for them to
link to the information they link to we
could all agree it's extremely
irresponsible and when you looked at the
nick sandman case there's sort of a
similar situation where they made the
entire country hate this kid and then in
the name of the story the covington
school kids they told you where he went
to school
so it would be very easy for someone to
find and hurt him and the people he was
with based on that information
yeah did he sue washington post too i
believe he sued washington post and
attempted to sue cnn but i can double
check this out thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you